[Musique]
nous quittons donc le combat cet
établissement de santé unique en son
genre situé en Indre-et-Loire spécialisé
dans l'accueil des membres des forces de
l'ordre et que vient de nous faire
découvrir ce documentaire réalisé par
Dominique Ath plus que le lieu ce sont
vous venez de le voir les témoignages
des policiers de passage dans cet
établissement qui frappe dans ce film
tellement il semble en dire long très
long sur les souffrances ressenties dans
l'exercice de leur métier de quoi
s'interroger sur la prise en compte des
troubles psychologiques auxquels doivent
souvent faire face ceux qui sont chargés
de notre sécurité c'est ce que nous
allons faire maintenant avec mes invités
présentes sur ce plateau de débat doc en
commençant par vous Yves Lefebvre
bienvenue à vous et vous êtes policier
vous êtes secrétaire général
fsmi Force ouvrière et président de
l'anasse l'Association nationale
d'action sociale qui gère entre autres
établissement du Courbat où a été tourné
le documentaire que nous venons de voir
merci pour votre présence sur ce plateau
Valentin Gendreau est également avec
nous bienvenue et vous êtes journaliste
connu pour vos infiltrations dans le
milieu policier après avoir suivi la
formation de l'école de police de
Saint-Malo avec la clé 2 livres suite à
cet infiltration
journalistique bien entendu le premier
livre s'intitule flic il a été publié
aux éditions de la Goutte d'Or vous
témoignez notamment de votre passage au
commissariat du 19e arrondissement de
Paris on y reviendra dans un instant et
puis il y a eu l.i.3p infiltré le
service psychiatrique de la police
racontée de l'intérieur c'est le dernier
ouvrage il a été publié chez Albin
Michel
vous pouvez peut-être nous en dire un
tout petit peu plus sur ce qu'est I3P
dans la police nationale
c'est une structure très particulière
parce que c'est ça fait office d'urgence
psychiatrique
pour des gens qui sont interpellés par
des policiers à Paris donc les policiers
peuvent orienter des gens vers le
l'infirmerie psychiatrique qui fait elle
ensuite fait office de gare de triage et
les gens peuvent être ensuite
hospitalisés vers la psychiatrie ou ils
peuvent retourner en garde à vue on a eu
un exemple assez récent cet homme qui a
tué des des membres de la communauté
kurde qui a été un temps envoyé à les 3P
et vous avez donc été affecté tout
d'abord
les 3P
et ensuite dans ce fameux commissariat
du 19e arrondissement durant les deux
ans pendant lesquels vous êtes infiltrés
au sein de la police nationale Marie
pesait est également avec nous sur ce
plateau bienvenue à vous on vous a vu
entendu dans le film que nous venons de
voir vous êtes docteur en psychologie
psychanalyste et spécialiste de la
souffrance au travail vous êtes entre
autres l'auteur de ce livre apprenez de
reconnaître et prévenir le burn-out puis
vous êtes je sais que vous y tenez
beaucoup la responsable du réseau de
consultation souffrance et travail
disons-nous un mot de ce réseau parce
que chacun est tous ses selles qui sont
policiers qui nous regardent aujourd'hui
peuvent vous appeler bien sûr j'ai créé
la première consultation souffrance et
travaille en 96 puis un diplôme
spécifique de prise en charge de ces
pathologies et il y a maintenant 200
consultations qui m'a et le territoire
français qu'on trouve en ligne sur le
site souffrance et travail nous prenons
bien sûr en charge les policiers entre
autres et vous travaillez notamment avec
une association qui s'appelle asso Paul
qui situait en région entre autres
bien on va attaquer tout de suite
directement si vous voulez bien se débat
autour de de ces chocs post-traumatiques
de ces dépressions de ces burnout qui
frappent une partie des policiers qui
peuvent même amener à des suicides et
des pass on rappelle tout de même ce
chiffre évidemment le taux de suicide
aujourd'hui dans la police nationale et
supérieure d'un tiers celui du reste de
la population et à ce sujet Gérald
Darmanin le ministre de l'intérieur
était interviewé en février 2002 il
disait ceci céder drame ont je cite un
lien direct avec la vie personnelle et
non pas professionnelle alors première
question est-ce qu'on en est encore là
est-ce qu'on en est encore dans ce déni
finalement du problème posé aujourd'hui
par le documentaire et celui qui fait
l'objet de notre échange aujourd'hui
même si ça tend à s'améliorer on est
encore dans une forme de déni oui
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui effectivement
pourquoi parce que le il n'y a jamais
qu'un seul critère au passage à light
c'est pas madame qui bien évidemment je
pense me dira le contraire mais il y a
je dirais une accumulation de choses le
flic qui est de moins en moins bien
reconnu dans la société en fonction qui
plus est de son lieu d'affectation le
flic n'est pas formé il est confronté
une violence à la
la souffrance ou quotidien et avec une
hiérarchie
de proximité comme somitale qui n'est
pas capable d'appréhender ce problème
qui n'est pas capable de l'écouter qui
n'est pas capable de l'accompagner qui
n'est pas capable de lui faire passer la
page je dirais de l'événement et qui
puisse sectionner en bonne et due forme
alors oui effectivement aussi dans ce
film c'est qu'il n'est pas bon d'avoir
des états d'âme dans ce métier c'est une
marque de faiblesse et ça concourt
beaucoup à une non prise de parole au
sein des commissariats des unités etc
dans votre métier faut pas en avoir du
moins là encore on essaye de de forcer
l'association nationale la NAS mais
aussi des syndicats je dirais
constructif font en sorte aujourd'hui
qu'on puisse pouvoir justement prétendre
à dire un moment donné que le flic a
droit d'avoir peur trop longtemps le
flic n'a pas le droit d'avoir peur et le
flingue reconnaît pas avoir eu peur
parce qu'il sait qu'autour de lui il va
être appréhendé regarder épier d'une
façon différente un flic s'implique en
qui on pourrait ne plus avoir confiance
sur le terrain mais c'est faux le flic
c'est un être humain c'est une femme
c'est un homme c'est un papa c'est une
maman qui a le droit de souffrir et
d'appréhender dans sa chair dans son âme
ce qu'il a vu ce qu'il a subi l'écoute
il a reçu mais pas que les coûts
physiques les kumoro aussi un flic n'a
pas le droit d'avoir peur pour reprendre
votre expression il a pas le droit
d'avoir peur d'une interpellation par
exemple mais il a pas le droit d'avoir
peur aux regards
de ces confrères policiers surtout parce
que cette marque de faiblesse elle
tendrait à prouver qu'elle que cette
personne n'a plus sa place dans les
rangs de la police bien sûr parce que
vous avez une hiérarchie aujourd'hui
encore malheureusement trop endoctrine
dans la politique du chiffre et
qu'aujourd'hui un flic qui va avoir peur
mais est-ce que ce flic je vais pouvoir
l'envoyer sur une opération un flic qui
est embryade antique humanité et qui
dirige j'ai eu peur et peut-être que son
chef de service peut-être que ça
hiérarchie direct
va dire à un moment donné mais on peut
plus le laisser dans cette situation là
donc on va le changer de service il va
plus pouvoir faire ce qu'il aime faire
au quotidien ce qu'il passionne et on va
l'envoyer dans un autre service on va le
mettre sur une voie de garage parce
qu'il a osé dire à un moment donné bah
oui là j'ai eu peur d'ailleurs pour ça
que à la NAS on y verra sûrement on a
des projets on veut pouvoir abandonner
créer des sessions de formation de
débriefing de je dirais de de
ressourcement après des grandes
opérations je pense aussi notamment à
mes collègues CRS quand ils subissent
des violons urbaines à répétition
pendant plusieurs jours un verre par les
dubril tout de suite rajouter quelque
chose oui je voulais rajouter que le
policier n'a pas le droit de montrer à
ses collègues qu'il a peur c'est quelque
chose qui est complètement interdit si
vous montrez à vos collègues que vous
avez peur moi je parle de l'expérience
que j'ai vécu au cours de mon
infiltration dans la police en 2019
si vous me montrez à vos collègues que
vous avez peur vous allez leur montrer
que vous n'êtes pas digne de porter
l'uniforme vous allez leur montrer que
vous n'êtes pas fiable sur le terrain
donc même si vous n'avez pas envie d'y
aller pour des raisons X ou Y
vous allez pas le montrer
policier c'est un métier où Madame
pesait le dit très bien dans le
documentaire tout ce que l'on fait c'est
négatif lorsque l'on est policier des
gens qui viennent au commissariat pour
déposer des plaintes c'est négatifs des
interventions c'est négatives ce sont
des accidents de la route ce sont des
morts à domicile ce sont des
cambriolages qui tournent mal
au bout d'un moment les policiers ils
peuvent en avoir marre ils peuvent avoir
des de vraies failles psychologiques
vous avez pas voir le montrer ça c'est
un vrai problème durant votre expérience
dans le commissariat du 19e
arrondissement un de vos collègues bien
sûr à l'époque est passé à l'acte s'est
suicidé
de l'intérieur se suicident d'un de vos
collègues moi je connais du 19e je
connaissais pas ce policier là c'est à
dire que même quand j'ai vu son visage
je l'ai croisé mais je dois pas être
très physionomiste il me semblait pas
l'avoir croisé avant est-ce qu'on en a
parlé entre collègues après le passage à
lattes c'était dans une autre c'était
dans une autre brigade je sais que ça a
été un vrai tremblement de terre pour
les pour les collègues de ce de ce jeune
homme qui s'est suicidé pour les gens
qui étaient dans ma brigade il y avait
un côté bon maintenant on passe à autre
chose
on va passer un extrait je vous donne la
parole juste après c'est votre collègue
psychologue justement au cours bas qui
s'exprime regardez
ce qui est spécifique c'est peut-être le
rapport aux émotions le rapport qu'ils
entretiennent aux émotions du fait de la
culture policière il y a une culture
très viriliste dans ces métiers là je
pense aussi aux femmes qui ont une
double contrainte puisque
elles doivent à la fois
être dans la retenue émotionnelle contre
l'émotionnelle comme les hommes et en
plus qui se mettent cette contrainte de
se dire faut que je me fasse ma place au
milieu des hommes et donc je dois encore
plus montrer que ça m'atteint pas et
voilà
c'était Margot feuillard qui s'exprimait
milieu viriliste et double peine pour
les femmes policières parce qu'il s'agit
aussi en plus du reste de cette gestion
des émotions de s'imposer dans un milieu
d'homme vous êtes d'accord avec ce
qu'elle dit moi je voudrais revenir sur
la question des suicides que vous avez
évoqués en début d'émission parce que
quand vous dites que un tiers de plus
que la population nationale
c'est une erreur statistique parce que
toutes les Suisses entre 31 vous voyez
et 41% tous les professionnels qui ont
lieu en lien avec le travail que ce soit
à l'hôpital dans la magistrature ou là
dans la police sont à comparer à des
suicides en milieu clos comme le suicide
en prison et donc on doit s'éloigner des
statistiques nationales ce qui fait que
le taux actuel de suicide des policiers
est terrifiant il est supérieur
celui du taux de suicide en prison c'est
à dire à celui d'un milieu clos c'est
comme ça qu'il faut regarder les choses
en plus ils sont armés donc ils ont un
accès direct à ce qui peut leur
permettre de service qui semble en ce
moment-là et au-delà du suicide qui
concerne beaucoup de lieux de travail et
qui sont bien sûr en lien avec les
nouvelles formes d'organisation du
travail
ce que vous évoquiez tout à l'heure
c'est à dire quand quelqu'un jeune se
suicide c'est pas du tout on va essayer
de comprendre quel est le chemin causal
qui a pu qui est multifactorielle mais
qui a pu conduire du côté du travail
c'est à dire la solitude l'excès de
stress la souffrance éthique de faire
des choses qu'on répond on va pas faire
ce débriefing là on va dire on passe à
autre chose ce qui fait que celui qui
n'est pas bien va se dire de toute façon
ça ne sert à rien que je parle de mes
difficultés puisque personne ne va
écouter et que même si je me tue on
passera autre chose donc c'est pour ça
que j'insistais tellement sur
l'existence de toutes les consultations
parce qu'il faut que les policiers qui
vont écouter cette émission les femmes
de policiers et les familles de
policiers sachent qu'il y a des lieux où
on peut en amont avant cette crise
suicidaire qui malheureusement est
souvent extrêmement rapide comme un
raptus qu'on peut recevoir ces gens-là
et les aider à comprendre pourquoi ils
n'en peuvent plus il faut que vous
compreniez que les policiers vous l'avez
suggéré ont à faire avec le mal au
quotidien les sexuel les meurtres les
violences de tous les jours qu'est-ce
que vous croyez que ça fait un policier
qui rentre le soir chez lui j'ai
longtemps habité dans un endroit que je
vais pas citer il y avait une
commissaire dans l'immeuble qui
s'occupait des de la pédophilie sur
Internet et qui s'arrêtait toujours chez
moi en me disant je ne peux pas remonter
chez moi et voir mes enfants au hasard
avec ce que j'ai dans la tête donc
qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour que les
policiers sur le terrain le soir puisse
ensemble mettre en commun les bonnes
défenses et se dire voilà ce qu'il
aurait fallu faire vous allez répondre
ou compléter évidemment dans un instant
vous n'avez pas répondu à ma question
double peine pour les femmes policières
en l'occurrence ou pas
les Français c'est toujours la double
peine pour les femmes partout dans la
police puisqu'on est dans un milieu
viril c'est encore
vous savez le présentéisme en France
c'est une valeur très virile dans
l'entreprise et donc les femmes aussi
sont à la double peine vous pensez qu'il
y a pas plus de double peine dans la
police que dans l'enseignement dans
l'éducation nationale je parle pas de
l'éducation nationale je pense aux
grandes entreprises où il faut rester
très tard si on veut faire sa place vous
souhaitez réagir
le taux de suicide le nombre de suicides
46 suicides en 2022
nous avions constaté en 2020 59 suicides
nationales
multifactoriel c'est un des éléments qui
ont amené Gérald Darmanin déclarer
février dernier multifactorielle oui
mais multifactoriels pourquoi je vous le
disiez madame le flic confronté à la
souffrance la détresse à la misère
rentre chez lui
ne change pas de cerveau change pas de
cœur quand il rentre chez lui donc bien
évidemment ça va polluer son
environnement familial le fait que le
flic soit reconnu dans la rue que le
flic ne puisse plus que ses enfants ne
puissent plus dire pas pas maman et flic
policier bien évidemment ça va induire
un malaise à la maison avec de plus en
plus nous sommes la profession qui
souffrons le plus des suicides mais nous
sommes l'une des professions qui
souffrons le plus des divorces donc tous
ces éléments rupture de la cellule
familiale liée au métier et pour le mes
collègues féminines
aujourd'hui effectivement elle doit
faire preuve dans un milieu un peu macho
un peu viril mais c'est la problématique
de l'appréhension des femmes dans la
police nationale c'est encore un
problème lié à la définition des
fonctions une femme dans la police
nationale n'a pas à faire preuve de sa
virilité une femme dans pays nationale
doit être là pour justement apporter
l'élément nécessaire pour appréhender
entre autre chose malheureusement ce
qu'il y a quasi palpable pas beaucoup
quotidien de plus en plus les femmes
battues les femmes maltraitées les
femmes violentées les femmes menacées et
c'est là qu'on doit travailler mais on a
fait tout et n'importe quoi dans la
police nationale à vouloir faire de mes
collègues féminines quasiment des
des mecs des mecs voilà merci Madame des
mecs et ça c'est on a eu tout faux là
dessus et tous les ministres succédés
depuis 1982 qui est la véritable entrée
des femmes dans le corps des gardiens de
la paix ont eu tous tout faux jusqu'à
présent le débriefing après des
opérations vous l'avez évoqué le sujet
on va voir un extrait ce à ce propos
c'est une ancienne policière qui
témoigne dans le documentaire que nous
avons vu
moi je me souviens des interventions
qu'on faisait qui sont traumatisantes
pour le restant de notre vie on y pense
mais jamais
on nous disait bon comment est-ce que
vous avez vu vécu cette intervention
quand vous trouvez des enfants morts des
des femmes ou des hommes assassinés ou
des accidents ou vous avez des gens qui
sont en morceaux jamais personne nous
dit comment est-ce que vous avez vécu
cette histoire comment vous avez vécu
cette opération comment vous avez vécu
ce maintien de l'ordre auquel vous avez
participé cet après-midi est-ce que dans
l'expérience vécue que vous avez vécu au
sein de la police nationale il y avait
des débriefings après chaque opération
ou certaines opérations plus délicates
que d'autres ou alors pas du tout non
seulement c'est pas quelque chose que
j'ai que j'ai pu voir la ce qu'on vient
d'entendre là je pense que c'est la
l'intervention la plus importante du
documentaire
c'est à dire que à aucun moment on va
parler de
dans un commissariat on va parler de
choses comme le stress post-traumatique
de la confrontation à la mort de
l'accumulation de la violence au
quotidien cette femme a tout résumé je
pense que ça c'est le vrai nom du
problème il y a pas ça n'existe pas ça
dans un commissariat on fait comme si
on passe à autre chose quoi moi je peux
vous raconter un petit exemple un jour
on est en intervention et on va dans
l'appartement de quelqu'un qui vient de
décéder ça fait trois jours qu'il est
décédé les pompiers
ont cassé la porte fenêtre et nous parce
que la parce qu'il y a une ouverture et
que des gens pourraient s'infiltrer dans
le dans l'appartement on est obligé de
rester dans l'appartement
c'est un monsieur de 70 ans qui est
décédé dans son lit voilà
ce jour là les policiers qui sont qui
étaient présents font un espèce de
concours de acquis aura vu le la mort la
plus horrible donc on est sur du suicide
on est sur des choses des gens décédées
depuis longtemps parce qu'évidemment ça
ce sont des choses que les policiers
rencontrent sur le terrain on parlait
tout à l'heure des accidents de la route
mais vous avez aussi des gens qui sont
décédés depuis longtemps et qu'on va par
exemple le retrouver l'été avec la
chaleur voilà donc ça tout ça c'est
évidemment totalement traumatique mais
alors le débrief derrière voilà vous n'y
pensez même pas et en tout cas moi je
n'ai pas vu vrai effectuer ce débrief au
sein des commissariats des unités je
vous poserai la question ensuite et puis
vous nous direz ce que vous en pensez
bien entendu
la hiérarchie qui est en cause non mais
la hiérarchie n'est pas présente sur le
terrain donc c'est pas on va pas leur
demander ça ils sont dans les dans la
paperasse ils sont dans l'administratif
ils sont pas sur le terrain les moines
tous les commissaires et les officiers
qui mènent les opérations sur le terrain
qui d'après votre expérience devrait
mener célébreries auprès peut-être d'un
certain nombre de policiers qu'on
participait à ces opérations parce que
pour tout ce qui est de l'ordre du du
traumatisme il y a des gens qui sont
qualifiés pour ça donc c'est le métier
psychologue psychologue du travail
psychologue cliniciens alors
effectivement la hiérarchie bon les RH
semitale différentes politiques de
gestion
en fait que c'est ils sont de loués
aujourd'hui dans des dans des dans des
stats dans des tableaux à remplir dans
des tableaux de bord je te sais-je
encore des officiers qui aujourd'hui ont
perdu leur place complètement dans le
dans le dans le schéma de fonctionnement
la prise nationale aujourd'hui ce que
moi j'attends de j'avoue que j'ai été
très surpris d'apprendre ce type de
choses dans ce documentaire aujourd'hui
aucun débrie sur les opérations
très délicates très meurtrières
aujourd'hui et je m'en félicite même si
c'est bien évidemment immensément
insuffisant c'est après une ouverture de
feu j'ai connu maigre expérience de
bientôt 41 ans de police des ouvertures
de feu par mes collègues ou il n'y avait
pas de débrief après il n'y avait pas de
débrief
le ou la psychologue ne franchissait
jamais la porte le seuil d'un
commissariat parce qu'ils étaient déjà
en nombre insuffisants il y a eu un
effort de fait là-dessus faut savoir
souligner si bien et parfois si je suis
pas bien mais aussi souligné ce qui va
un peu mieux il y a eu aujourd'hui mais
le problème aujourd'hui qu'il faut qu'on
forme le policier dans le dans le
premier encadrant c'est le
brigadier-chef de police c'est le
premier encadrant aujourd'hui il doit
être formé dans son cursus de passage de
grade à appréhender à savoir débriefer
et pourquoi aujourd'hui on a créé
effectivement on crée des sentinelles
actuellement dans un pays national Alana
son a décidé aussi de venir en couple
ça s'inspire de ce quelque chose qui a
été mis en place à Montréal je crois et
ce sont en réalité
peut-être des policiers les plus
expérimentés d'une unité d'un
commissariat en tout cas qui ont été
repérés comme étant à même oui de faire
parler leurs collègues effectivement
d'enregistrer les souffrances
psychologiques dont ils ont pu faire
l'objet à l'occasion ces fameuses
sentinelles sont semble-t-il en train
peu à peu de se mettre en place dans
certaines unités
SI encore très long trop long pourquoi
parce que vous savez vous avez les
soutiennent la volonté à les bonnes la
volonté du directeur général de Frédéric
Vaud de le mettre ses sentinelles c'est
un projet initié par son prédécesseur
quand on est sentinelle doit être trop
long terme j'insiste bien en théorie je
peux vous citer un exemple très récent à
la brigade du chemin de fer de la police
aux frontière gare du Nord ou un garçon
qui a de l'empathie pour écouter
appréhender qui sent qui peut aider ses
collègues se fait taper ce bois menacé
d'être sanctionné par une hiérarchie
d'un autre temps en disant mais
qu'est-ce qu'on n'a pas besoin de vous
on n'a pas besoin de sentir et ça c'est
un des principaux fléaux et ananas on
vient en complément on a formé presque
40 cm depuis le début 2022 pour venir
justement complément certainement pas en
opposition ce si on est en plus nombreux
mieux structuré que nous arriverons à
peut-être enfin appréhender cette
problématique l'important de comprendre
que le premier obstacle c'est ce dont on
parlait la culture viriliste quand le
bureau de la psychologue est dans le
couloir de la hiérarchie vous croyez
qu'un policier va aller voir le
psychologue pour essayer de se faire
aider vous parler de souffrance
psychique moi je dirais que ce sont les
conséquences de l'exercice du métier si
on regarde les choses comme ça c'est
mieux parce qu'autrement ça laisse à
penser que le policier qui ne tient pas
sur ces opérations en insistant à ces
meurtres en allant sur de crime et
quelqu'un de fragile ça fait ça à tout
le monde et ce qui peut aider le plus
au-delà des spécialistes qui s'affaires
leur métier c'est le soutien social le
soutien collectif c'est une équipe qui
va discuter à la fin de la journée
qu'est-ce qu'on aurait pu mieux faire
moi dans ces cas-là je faisais ça tu
sais la prochaine fois ne fait pas ça
parce que tu te mets en péril
psychologiquement c'est à dire la
transmission des savoir-faire de métiers
qui est pas dans les manuels qui est pas
dans la formation initiale qui est trop
courte et qui se transmet de seniors à
nos voisins et ça ça n'existe plus et
puis je voudrais insister sur le fait
parce que c'est l'expérience
vécueillez qu'on va voir un psychologue
lorsqu'on est
un aveu de faiblesse j'ai même lu que
certains disaient qu'il n'y avait pas de
secret médical au sein c'est impensable
nous sommes tous de la police c'est
important parmi les cellules
psychologiques qui sont mis en place
aujourd'hui nous sommes soumis c'est
pour ça qu'on y va pas parce que la
hiérarchie serait informée ici ou là on
fait l'objet d'une faiblesse
psychologique et qu'à ce moment-là bien
on se met en danger pour
nous des policiers qui sont sous les
ordres d'un commissaire qui leur dit je
ne veux pas que mon chiffre de RPS
augmente donc je t'enlève ton arme mais
tu ne t'arrêtes pas en maladie RPS vous
pouvez nous risque psychosociaux tous
les gens qui écoutent connaissent
Valentin Gendreau peut-être quelque
chose là oui je voulais juste aller un
peu plus loin je moi ça me fait penser à
la formation à ce que l'on donne en
formation policiers et aussi à l'image
de mythification du métier pour des gens
qui veulent devenir policiers la
mythification pour moi c'est par exemple
les séries engrenage c'est les films
d'Olivier Marchal je pense par exemple
que ce monsieur même si ces films à mon
sens sont bons entretient l'image du
superflic
quand vous êtes sur le terrain
dans le 19e arrondissement comme ça a
été mon cas vous n'êtes pas un super
flic vous faites pas de la grande police
vous n'êtes pas maintenant de police
judiciaire qui a une vie de dingue et
qui fait des affaires de dingue vous
êtes vous pouvez rester 4 heures 5
heures sur un accident de la route à
faire la circulation voilà je voulais
simplement rajouter ça je voudrais
parler du sspo le service de soutien
psychologique opérationnel de la police
on va dire appelons ça à la cellule
interne oui totalement oui bien sûr 122
postes de psychologue à plein temps
aujourd'hui dont 20 postes d'ailleurs
incréés en 2022 donc il y a peut-être
effectivement une prise de conscience en
interne et mais finalement il semblerait
à la lecture d'un certain nombre
d'articles qui effectivement les
policiers hésitent à aller voir cette
fameuse cellule interne et préfère avoir
accès à des services externalisés pour
parler de leur souffrance psychologique
oui bien sûr les problèmes madame madame
le disait le roi était parfaitement
quand vous avez le bureau de la
psychologue qui est dans le même bureau
parfois en face du chef de service d'un
officier ou même à grader de la police
nationale qui va dénoncer de suite le
fait que Dupont est allé voir la psy
prévenir le chef de service en disant et
de fait de fait c'est comme dans tout
Corporation il y a des gens intelligents
il y a des gens qui sont beaucoup moins
et des gens qui ont peur qui sont là
pour un déroulement de carrière
effectivement ce sont des critères
d'évaluation les risques psychosociaux
donc partons de là on va dire ouh là
Dupont la psy mais Dupont on va le
laisser au poste maintenant il va rester
ou pas s'il ne va plus être on va le
préserver du pont ou pire j'avoue citer
un autre exemple très récent hier
à de mes délégués et reçu dans le cadre
d'une procédure contradictoire
administrative son chef de service avant
même de l'avoir entendu décide de le
désarmer et décide de le demander sa
suspension directeur général de la
police nationale imaginez-vous procédure
contradictoires il est pas entendu et on
décide déjà de le suspendre tu aurais pu
faire mon collègue si nous n'avions pas
été là pour le préserver avec fort
heureusement des gens dignes de
confiance dans un autre niveau de la
hiérarchie notre collègue pouvait se
sentir d'un seul coup passer de victime
a mis en cause il n'avait plus de sens à
son métier il n'avait plus son arme il
était suspendu qu'elle est-il expliqué
entre chez lui ce garçon-là pouvait
passer à light tout simplement et c'est
ça ce qu'on attend aujourd'hui ce que
j'attends aujourd'hui c'est simplement
d'une capacité de discernement il y a
des gens qui sont capacité de le faire
qui sont un peu moins mais pour ça il
faut former les gens parce que le flic
le flic vous le relatiez tout à l'heure
avec pertinence j'apprécie les films
d'Olivier Marchal c'est un peu moins
parfois c'est certaines de ces prises de
position sur le monde policier que je
prétends un tout petit peu connaître
mais c'est pas ça le beau flic vous
savez le seul le seul film de c'est un
film qui nous a fait beaucoup sourire
pour les gens de notre génération
c'était Pinot simple flic
et aujourd'hui moi ce que j'attends d'un
réalisateur c'est qu'il soit capable de
me faire un film sur ce style
véritablement le métier de 110 000
gradés et gardiens de la paix
aujourd'hui de vivre à l'intérieur de
vivre chez mes collègues CRS qui vont
subir des violences qui ont souffert
pendant les gilets jaunes de subir des
violences d'être appelé intervenir à
20h30 après 16 heures de travail 16
heures de combat de violence urbaine
intervenir dans un établissement à
Burger King en excluence un côté
Champs-Élysées de se retrouver quelques
mois après sur le banc des accusés alors
qu'il n'avaient simplement répondu qu'il
y a des ordres donnés par la préfecture
de police de Paris ce jour-là et ces
gens-là ont pensé pour certains d'entre
eux à passer à l'acte à un moment donné
alors le passage à l'acte justement la
tentative de suicide il en est bien
évidemment question dans le film que
nous avons eu l'occasion de regarder
ensemble dernière extrait de ce
documentaire
plusieurs fois j'ai porté là à ma
tête à ma tante
je résistais je résistais je résistais
pour pas tirer parce que peut-être
pourquoi j'ai résisté j'en sais rien
peut-être qu'il a un moment à l'instant
T le téléphone a sonné ou peut-être
qu'on a parlé ou quelque chose a vu que
j'avais que j'allais faire une bêtise et
j'ai reposé l'arme
mais par sécurité j'ai demandé à être
exempté de port d'arme
dans ce documentaire vous évoquez les
suicides blancs elle est Sud rouge vous
nous en dire plus quel est le distinguo
et pourquoi avoir parlé de en
psychopathologie
du travail en les classes en couleur les
suicides noires c'est ça pourrait être
des policiers qui ont des antécédents et
que la situation de travail va aggraver
le suicide rouge et le policier qui va
se tuer en espérant qu'après on va
parler des conditions de travail de ce
qui se passe sur le terrain un peu comme
chez France Télécom sauf que la chape de
plomb comme vous l'avez si bien dit se
referme et que le silence ne fait que ça
croître les suicides blancs sont au
recrudescence dans tous les milieux
professionnels c'est je veux juste que
ça s'arrête et je ne sais pas comment
m'en sortir c'est la partie étroite de
l'entonnoir qui conduit au burn out
absolu mais qui conduit aussi au passage
à l'acte quand on a une arme à
disposition comme dans les hôpitaux de
prendre les cachets sur le plateau quand
on est médecin ou s'injecter ce qu'il
faut
le suicide blanc c'est le suicide du
désespoir du découragement j'ai beau
avoir alerté ma hiérarchie j'ai beau
avoir essayé de faire remonter mes
difficultés j'ai beau expliquer que
cette culture du SRI enlève le sens de
mon travail j'ai beau essayer de
m'appuyer sur sur mes collègues le
collectif n'existe plus je ne vois pas
d'issue je vois pas de fenêtre je vois
pas de de bout de lumière à ce tunnel et
donc je veux juste que cette souffrance
s'arrête
moi je pense que le la question du
suicide c'est
du suicide des policiers c'est comme ça
depuis 40 ans 50 ans c'est c'est traité
en 20 lignes dans la dans la presse
c'est 15 secondes à la série en moyenne
par semaine
mais ça n'intéresse pas le politique je
crois je crois je crois qu'on va plus
parler de criminalité de délinquance que
de suicide alors qu'à mon avis la police
a plus à craindre des suicides que des
criminels ça c'est une vraie donnée mais
si aujourd'hui on a un pays avec la
police le métier de policier c'est le
deuxième métier de France où il y a plus
de suicide dans les agriculteurs la
question t'apprendre à bras le corps et
ça c'est au ministre de l'Intérieur de
le faire et à personne d'autre
petite lumière au bout du tunnel par
rapport au sujet que nous traitons
aujourd'hui autrement dit est-ce que
vous avez senti un temps soit peu de
d'évolution sur la prise en compte des
troupes psychologiques chez chez les
policiers à travers votre expérience le
suivi que vous avez pu en faire
maintenant puis depuis quelques mois
est-ce qu'il y a une demande réelle qui
émerge du côté des des policiers dans ce
que vous avez pu regarder puis entendre
je n'ai pas l'impression j'ai pas
l'impression vous avez les politiques
sentinelles qui sont qui sont mis en
place ce sont des je pense que c'est une
bonne chose moi je pense qu'il faut
aller plus loin je pense qu'il faudrait
un suivi psychologique pour tous les
policiers de ce pays
30 minutes une heure plusieurs fois par
an et la question c'est dans d'autres
pays ce type de suffrage j'en sais rien
mais je pense que quand vous avez 50 60
policiers qui mettent fin à leurs jours
par an on peut se poser la question vous
avez aussi la question de l'arme à
domicile vous avez 75% des policiers qui
se suicident de service c'est une
question qu'on peut se poser aussi quand
même et d'ailleurs la femme qu'on a
entendu dans cet extrait a demandé à ce
qu'on lui retire l'arme de service oui
l'arme de service l'arme de service
j'étais au poste responsabilité déjà au
moment où on a adopté le le port de
l'arbre en dehors des heures de service
c'était après le drame bien évidemment
l'assassinat de nos deux collègues dans
les Yvelines on sait tous posé la
question de savoir est-ce que on devait
le faire ou pas le souci il est
effectivement c'est un passage avec
facilité
mais le policier est tellement menacé en
dehors de son temps de travail le
policier maintenant se doit d'intervenir
à tout moment et effectivement c'était
c'est un équilibre à trouver on ne l'a
malheureusement pas trouvé par contre je
vous rejoins pleinement ça fait partie
des revendications que l'on pose
régulièrement avec ma fédération
syndicale et le syndicat Unité HGP
police et la NAS l'évaluation
l'évaluation annuelle des policiers ça
existe dans d'autres métiers ça existe
dans des métiers on aurait du mal à
concevoir je m'imagine un commandant de
bord un pilote d'avion ne soit pas suivi
en la matière il faut que le policier le
soit également par rapport à ça il faut
aujourd'hui qu'on brise
tous ces paramètres il faut qu'on aille
plus loin aujourd'hui qu'on appréhende
vous savez vous parliez d'orange tout à
l'heure la société Orange j'ai eu songé
une époque pas avec la mission
intérieure
en partie ils sont prédécesseur à
déposer plainte à l'époque pour la mise
en danger de mes collègues et c'est
Orange et ça aboutit à une prise en
considération de ce profond mal-être il
faudra aussi que nous syndicalise nous
ayons aussi le courage peut-être un
moment donné elle est encore plus loin
dans nos actions en la matière et ça a
pris plus de 10 ans France Télécom donc
c'est pas pour demain que ça qu'on va
régler problème malheureusement en ligne
ici vraiment à tous les trois d'avoir
participé à ce débat doc on a découvert
cet établissement du Courbat à travers
ce documentaire avec derrière évidemment
la prise en compte des troupes
psychologiques chez les policiers qu'on
a évoqué ensemble sur ce plateau de
débat doc vos réactions ça sera sur
hashtag débadoc sur Twitter bien entendu
nos invités seront là pour réagir aussi
à ce que ce qu'on vaut réactions merci à
sel massali qui m'a aidé à préparer
cette émission à hautmorakini qui édite
cette émission et je vous donne tout
simplement rendez-vous pour un prochain
débat doc et ça sera bien entendu avec
son documentaire et son débat à très
bientôt
[Musique]